[Música]
una unidad de élite de pilotos
tripulaciones de manera remota para
combatir contra las fuerzas rusas o para
identificar un terreno tendremos la
historia de uno de los líderes de este
comando ucraniano
la corte suprema de justicia de honduras
ratificó la extradición del expresidente
juan orlando hernández
eeuu lo pide por cargos de narcotráfico
el ex mandatario llegará a suelo
estadounidense para enfrentar el juicio
un reconocimiento de la iglesia católica
por los crímenes en contra de niños
indígenas en las escuelas residenciales
esa fue la exigencia de tres delegados
que se reunieron con el papá francisco
en el vaticano les contaremos la
historia de minutos
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos y comenzamos a esta emisión
hablando de un escuadrón elite de drones
en ucrania de manera remota a los
pilotos operan aviones no tripulados ya
sea para reconocer el terreno o para
combatir es una de las maneras con las
que se enfrentan a los ataques aéreos
ordenados por rusia en algunos lugares
de ucrania realizan cientos de misiones
en un solo día france24 estuvo con uno
de sus líderes
son los ojos de los soldados ucranianos
en el campo de batalla este hombre es
uno de los comandantes de un escuadrón
de pilotos de drones operan aviones no
tripulados de reconocimiento así como de
combate muy próximo y trabajamos bien
noche los observamos determinamos su
ubicación exacta volamos y atacamos a
veces nos oyen porque algunos drones
tienen un sonido reconocible cuando oyen
ese sonido entonces podemos verlos huir
despavoridos tumbarse esconderse pero no
todos lo consiguen
juanes peones vuk su unidad es ahora
capaz de fabricar sus propios drones de
ataque como este dice que las tropas
rusas se han adaptado desde entonces
revolviendo atenga webs nuestro
principal reto es la falta de
equipamiento tenemos que reconocer que
nuestro enemigo trabaja muy duro y es
muy bueno en las contra operaciones en
la guerra electrónica así que casi todos
los días perdemos equipo por eso
seguimos pidiendo apoyo lo necesitamos y
vemos que llegan nuevos equipos de todo
el mundo lo pongo tengo aunque tres no
todos los vuelos diarios sobre la
capital confirman que las fuerzas rusas
han tenido dificultades en esta red
podemos ver muy bien lo que está
ocurriendo alrededor de quien se están
protegiendo y podemos ver que la
situación empieza a ser mala para
algunos de ellos a veces quedan cortados
de sus líneas de suministro sus
municiones alimentos y combustible les
está desmoralizando y podemos verlo la
situación en el frente oriental es muy
diferente su unidad lleva a cabo cientos
de misiones allí todos los días y son
conscientes de que la lucha será a largo
plazo
el presidente de estadounidense joe
biden defendió las palabras que
pronunció en polonia contra el
mandatario ruso vladimir putin al final
del discurso que dio el sábado bailén
dijo que putin no podía permanecer en el
poder los críticos lo señalaron de
querer un cambio de régimen en el
kremlin y este lunes el presidente
sostuvo que nadie estaba hablando de
derrocar a putin sino que él expresó lo
que llamó indignación moral por lo que
sentía hacia el líder ruso esto fue lo
que dijo el presidente estadounidense
número 1 no estoy retrocediendo en nada
el hecho de que estaba expresando más
indignación camps así que quiero dejar
claro que no estaba entonces ni estoy
ahora articulando un cambio de política
estaba expresando la indignación moral
que siento no pido disculpas
en honduras la corte suprema de justicia
ratificó la extradición del ex
presidente juan orlando hernández a eeuu
este país lo solicita por tráfico de
drogas y por conspiración por porte de
armas de fuego y dispositivos
destructivos espera que los próximos
días hernández entregado a las
autoridades estadounidenses
juan orlando hernández será extraditado
a eeuu así lo ratificó la corte suprema
de justicia de honduras que rechazó su
apelación luego de analizar todos los
agravios y los elementos que fueron
presentados por la defensa técnica en la
apelación planteada ha resuelto no al
lugar el recurso de apelación planteado
lo cual significa que se confirma la
decisión del juez de primera instancia
de conceder la extradición del ciudadano
juan orlando hernández el ex presidente
hondureño es acusado por la justicia
estadounidense de conspiración para
fabricar distribuir y poseer una
sustancia controlada y llevarla a eeuu y
usar o portar armas de fuego o ayudar a
instigar al uso de las mismas según el
portavoz del poder judicial la decisión
contó con el voto unánime de los
magistrados en el cargo de narcotráfico
y 13 contra 2 con respecto al cargo de
uso de armas
hernández de 53 años dijo en una carta
que compartió su esposo en su cuenta de
twitter que es inocente todo cambió
todos los planes que tenía para mi
retiro después de tantos años de trabajo
al final concluyó en la posibilidad de
que enfrentar cargos por tres cadenas
perpetuas podría llevarme a convertirme
en un muerto envío esto es una venganza
de los carteles es una trama orquestada
para que ningún gobierno vuelva a
hacerle frente el exmandatario fue
detenido en su domicilio el 15 de
febrero para la petición del gobierno
estadounidense y desde entonces ha
permanecido recluido en la dirección
nacional de fuerzas especiales de la
policía nacional la detención se produjo
en menos de tres semanas después de que
hernández dejara su cargo y tras años de
acusaciones de la fiscalía
estadounidense sobre presuntos vínculos
con el narcotráfico
el presidente del salvador buque le
advirtió a los pandilleros que paren de
matar o que si no sus compañeros que
están en prisión pagarán por ellos el
mandatario señaló que ya a los presos
les restringieron algunas medidas es que
el país entró en régimen de excepción
desde el domingo cuando el congreso lo
decretó a petición de google
esta medida suspende algunas garantías
constitucionales bush que le hizo su
advertencia a través de twitter una red
social que ha usado como herramienta
política
mensaje a las pandillas tenemos 16 mil
home voice en nuestro poder a parte de
los mil arrestados en estos días les
decomisamos todo hasta las colchonetas
para dormir les reaccionamos la comida y
ahora ya no verán el sol paren de matar
ya o ellos lo van a pagar también y
ahora hablamos de brasil el mandatario
ya ir bolsonaro destituyó al presidente
de petrobras la empresa de combustibles
semipública el general de la reserva de
joaquín silva el una ya no estará en el
cargo pues bolsonaro está inconforme con
el aumento de los precios del petróleo
el ministerio de minas y energía
presentó una lista con los nueve
candidatos que postula al consejo de
administración de la compañía y dentro
de ellos incluyó al posible sustituto
del presidente que sería adriano pires
miembros de las fuerzas armadas
mexicanas si participaron en la
manipulación de pruebas del caso de
ayotzinapa esa es la principal
conclusión del más reciente informe del
grupo de la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos que estudia el caso los
investigadores conocieron un vídeo
grabado en octubre de 2014 un mes
después de la desaparición de los 43
estudiantes las imágenes muestran a
miembros de la marina ocultando
información en el basurero de cocula en
medio de la investigación estos datos
habrían ayudado a encontrar a los
estudiantes según el grupo
y los pueblos de win it' y metis de
canadá quieren que la iglesia católica
reconozca los crímenes cometidos contra
miles de niños indígenas tres
representantes de las etnias se
reunieron con el papá francisco en el
vaticano exigen justicia por los
asesinatos las violaciones y los abusos
cometidos en contra de los menores que
vivían en el sistema de escuelas
residenciales católicas durante los años
1831 a
melissa chávez rincón con los detalles
la reunión con el papá francisco fue a
puerta cerrada
el pontífice escuchó a tres
representantes de los pueblos indígenas
quienes contaron lo que vivieron en las
escuelas residenciales dirigidas por la
iglesia católica en canadá en la visita
pidieron que el vaticano reconozca se
disculpe y se responsabilice por los
crímenes cometidos en contra de miles de
niños durante más de 165 años
y una disculpa genuina y sincera sería
un primer paso para empezar a sanar star
one king star healing esta es la primera
de cuatro reuniones que se realizarán a
lo largo de la semana en donde se
presentarán 39 testimonios de
violaciones y abusos los representantes
indígenas exigen acciones legales y
acceso sin restricciones a los registros
de las instituciones
si hay acusaciones de que alguien ha
cometido estos abusos deben ser llevados
ante la justicia y la iglesia no debe
interponerse en el camino sino ayudar a
quienes han sido víctimas a buscar
justicia y sanación station iván
aproximadamente 150.000 niños fueron
sacados de sus hogares y sometidos al
sistema de educación de las escuelas
residenciales católicas la comisión de
la verdad y reconciliación instaurada
para investigar los crímenes calificó lo
ocurrido como un genocidio cultural
nuestros niños llegaron a casa odiando
quienes eran odiando su idioma su
cultura y su tradición más de 4.000
niños murieron mientras asistían a las
140 escuelas de este tipo que existe en
canadá la comisión de la verdad estima
que la cifra real supera los 6000 por lo
que continúa en la búsqueda de restos
humanos en los alrededores de las
instituciones hasta aquí las noticias
sigan con nosotros
[Música]